so let me now
introduce today's speaker chris potts
christopher potts is professor of
linguistics
and by courtesy of computer science at
stanford university
he is the director of the center for the
study of language
and information at stanford in his
research he develops computational
models of linguistic reasoning
emotional expression and dialogue he is
the author of the book the logic of
conventional implicatures
and as well as numerous colored papers
in linguistics and natural language
processing
so thank you for joining us chris and
i'm happy to hand it over to you
thank you petra and thank you everyone
uh for turning out today i think this is
an exciting event
i also want to have the chance just want
to thank those course alums for coming
back
to talk about their work i think that's
very generous they did big and exciting
things during the course
and it's great for them to be reporting
out to you on what they achieved
to kick this off i think i just want to
say very boldly
that we live in the most exciting moment
in history for doing
work in natural language understanding
it really does feel like over the past
15 years we've seen some real
qualitative changes in what we're able
to do both with technology
and with kind of core scientific
development so
that's a very positive picture it really
is an exciting moment
on the other hand i think as
practitioners we can see that
some of the gains aren't what they first
seen that they're
that really the big questions are still
left
open and that's part of what makes this
such an exciting moment
is not just that we're able to do new
and exciting things but also that the
big research challenges
are still ahead of us and i think what i
can do today
is give you a full picture of that
through the lens of what i'm going to
call adversarial testing which is a new
mode
of evaluating our systems and looking
for ways to find problems with them
and improve them so here's kind of our
outline for today i do want to just
emphasize
under the heading of a golden age for
nlu that lots of exciting things are
happening
and i want that to be the overall
message that it really is an exciting
moment
however it's important that we take a
peek behind the curtain
and come to a measured understanding of
what this product this
progress is actually like and that will
kind of key us up to talk about
adversarial testing which is this more
technical
more strategic way that we as
practitioners
can find fault with our systems and then
look for ways to improve them
and that's kind of a nice transition
into the course work for xcs224u because
i think the tools and techniques
that we introduce are really great for
you know combining that with adversarial
testing
and finding new ways to make progress
well let's kick it off on this positive
note a golden age for nlu i've just
assembled
some examples that have to do with
natural language understanding
actually i could be talking about ai in
general because it really is a golden
age for the entire field
first example artificial assistance
these get a lot of the press these are
things like siri
and google home the more trusting among
you might have these devices in your
homes listening to you at
all times they certainly pass the bar in
terms of utility
they're able to help us with simple
tasks around the house
i also want to just call out the fact
that their speech to text capabilities
are astounding i think you know they're
good in the sense that 15 years ago the
things that they achieve
every day would have looked like science
fiction now
it's by no means a solved problem there
are plenty of remaining issues with that
speech to test
but again it really does feel like we've
made a phase change in terms of the
things we can achieve there
maybe for the nlu a little less as we'll
see
in a little bit we don't actually talk
about machine translation in the course
but i'd be remiss if i didn't bring it
up because this is another major
breakthrough area for
language technologies i've picked google
translate as kind of my example here
first of all google translate can take
you from dozens of input languages to
dozens of output languages
that alone is a kind of astounding
science and technology accomplishment
but it's also remarkable how good the
translations can be here just as a quick
example
i've put some english in on the left
i've got a french example on the right
and this is actually
a kind of example from a popular data
set so we have
a so-called gold translation here and
it's just striking how close
the translated text is to that human
gold standard
you have the usual mistakes in terms of
preposition
and maybe word choice and stylistics but
again
it really passes the bar in terms of
helping someone who
doesn't understand this input language
actually figure out what was expressed
and that's just something that wasn't
true 15 or 20 years ago for these mt
systems
image captioning is a really great kind
of grounded language
understanding task where the inputs are
images and the task is to assign them
accurate and interesting and descriptive
captions this is from a paper
a few years ago that was a really a
breakthrough paper i think on doing this
kind of metro language generation
and i just want to observe that these
captions are really great a person
riding a motorcycle on a dirt road
a group of young people playing a game
of frisbee this is fluent
makes it basically factually accurate
text that
is really good as a kind of caption for
those systems and again this just wasn't
something we could achieve
15 years ago another
major technology moment for me anyway
was
when ibm's watson system
won jeopardy the online game show
this is a really integrated technology
system that had to do lots of things
in order to play the game of jeopardy
but at the heart
this was a very powerful open domain
question answering system so i really do
mark this
as a win for nlu that it was able to be
super human in some sense on the show by
beating these two jeopardy champions
here
and then if we zoom in on the kind of
tasks that we actually focus on in the
course
i think we see a similar kind of picture
where
the kinds of things that we can do now
just feel very different from the kinds
of things we could do
15 years ago and it feels like we're on
the cusp of seeing some really
transformative things in the near future
as well
because it's a major unit for the course
i've picked natural language inference
as the task i'm going to focus on to
illustrate some of this stuff
so just briefly the task of natural
language inference or nli
you're given a premise and a hypothesis
text
and the task is to assign one of three
labels to that pair so in this case we
would assign the label entails
to the pair a turtle danced a turtle
moved the idea is that
any situation in which this premise
sentence which is true
would also be one in which this
hypothesis sentence was true
it's a kind of common sense reasoning
task here for the second example every
reptile danced is neutral with respect
to a turtle age because
they can be true or false independently
of each other
and finally some turtles walk and no
turtles move would be a contradiction in
this notion of common sense reasoning
so that's a fast overview of the nli
task there are a few major benchmark
data sets the first one the oldest one
is the stanford natural language
inference corpus
here what i've done is just map out on
the y-axis the f-1 score you can think
of that as a kind of notion of accuracy
for the system
and in the original paper we set a human
baseline of just short of 92 on this f1
score metric
that's this red line here across the
x-axis i have
time and so what we're going to look at
is published papers over time that have
tried to achieve new things on this
snli benchmark so here's the picture
what you see is first of all basically
sort of monotonic progress i think
people are learning from previous papers
and figuring out new tricks that help
them on the snli task
so you see a lot of very rapid progress
and then the striking thing is that
in the middle of last year we saw the
first what you might call
superhuman system for the snli task
so two things i want to say about that
first again this is not something that
we could have achieved
two decades ago it really is remarkable
that we even have systems that can enter
this kind of competition to say nothing
of actually surpassing this kind of
estimate of human performance
however what we have to keep in mind and
what we'll see in a little bit
is this that this does not mean that we
have systems that are super human when
it comes to the human task
of common sense reasoning all the hard
aspects of that problem
remain unsolved completely and i'm going
to make that very clear to you
but nonetheless it's striking that we
have systems that are even this good
in this narrowly circumscribed way
multi-nli is a very similar data set
it's just arguably harder because the
underlying data
is more diverse i have the same
framework here f1 score
and the human estimate is 92.6 so a
little bit higher
and i again have time along this x-axis
here
now it's kind of exciting that this data
set unlike the previous one is on kaggle
so many more people can enter and we can
get their scores
so the picture overall is there's a lot
more variance a lot more people are
entering and doing a lot more
interesting and diverse things but it's
a similar picture and that we can see
the community kind of
slowly hill climbing toward what is
eventually going to be superhuman
performance on this task
and that's exciting to see and nli just
to be clear
is not the only area in which we have
what you might call superhuman but in
quotes superhuman performance
here are a few other examples they
include speech technologies
translation question answering and glue
here is a big benchmark task that
captures
captures a lot of diverse things again
though you have to be really careful
about how you talk about this
what we have is systems that are
superhuman
on these particular data sets using a
very particular set of metrics this does
not mean that we have superhuman
performance
in any larger sense and that's the part
that i find exciting in fact these are
unsolved problems
but nonetheless you might look and
reflect back on this technology
and start to adopt the perspective
that's in this book by nick bostrom
called super intelligence where it kind
of
looks at the current state of technology
and begins to wonder
what life might be like when very soon
perhaps
we have systems that are vastly better
than humans at all of these kind of core
human abilities and he worries about
what the world and the universe might be
like
when we achieve those kind of
breakthroughs so have that picture in
mind i can see why people would arrive
at it given the golden age that we live
in
but i do want to temper that a little
bit so let's take a peek
behind the curtain at those examples i
mentioned those artificial agents
before that are in your houses you
probably experienced them in various
ways i think the dream
is that they'll be able to do things
like this you say any good burger joints
around here and it replies
i found a number of burger restaurants
near you and you say hmm
what about tacos and at that point your
device is able to recognize your
intention
very flexibly think about your language
and the context it's in
and kind of proactively help you solve
the problem that you've implicitly
defined for it
that's the dream i'm not sure how often
you all experience it
i want to balance that against this very
funny sketch from the stephen colbert
show from a number of years ago
so the premise is that stephen has been
playing with his iphone which has siri
on it
all day and he has failed to write his
television show so he says
for the love of god the cameras are on
give me something
and syria replies what kind of place are
you looking for camera stores or
churches
as practitioners we should pause there
and kind of realize what has happened
siri is doing some very superficial
keyword matching on the utterance
not deep language understanding and
that's why it has associated cameras
with camera stores
and god with churches so sort of a peek
behind the curtain there and then the
the interaction continues i don't want
to search for anything i want to write
the show
and siri does what siri often does
searching the web for search for
anything i want to write the shuffle
there's a small transcription error
there but i think the broader picture is
just that
siri does not have a deep understanding
of this interaction
and we're seeing on the surface here the
cheap tricks
that the device uses in order to try to
get past those limitations this is by no
means
open domain dialogue of the sort that we
were hoping for
translation again i think google
translate is an astounding technological
achievement
but it too shows that it doesn't have
deep understanding
for this example what i've done is just
input a bunch of random vowel sequences
this is the trick i learned from the
language log website completely random
input here
it's interesting that it had that it has
inferred that this is the hawaiian
language if you know something about
hawaiian syllable structure you might
grant
that that is at least an interesting
hypothesis about this input
nonetheless it is completely random the
really disconcerting part is that on the
right here in english we have
a completely fluent sentence that by
definition has nothing to do with that
nonsense input
and even stranger if i make very small
changes on the left
i'll get a completely fluent but
completely different
sentence out on the right and this is
revealing that these systems don't know
anything about their own
uncertainty and certainly don't
understand the inputs they're processing
i showed you before those examples from
image captioning to their credit from
this
this excellent paper here they didn't
just show the really successful cases
here we have a spectrum from the really
good ones on the left to the really kind
of embarrassing ones on the right
this middle one says a refrigerator
filled with lots of food and drinks
it's actually a sign with some stickers
on it a yellow school bus parked in a
lot
is kind of close but really not like
what the human understanding of those
scenes is
so lots of work to be done even in the
narrowly subscribed
space of image captioning i mentioned
before that i think watson was a really
breakthrough technology moment
for especially open domain question
answering but again watson did not
understand what it was processing here's
a sort of funny interaction
you have to remember that jeopardy kind
of reverses its questions and answers so
the answer came
grasshoppers eat it and watson's reply
was kosher
which seems completely disjointed it's
not a guess that a human would make
but if you realize that watson was
primarily trained on lots of wikipedia
entries
and you look up grasshoppers on
wikipedia you'll find very rich
discussions of whether modern-day
grasshoppers
are kosher so there is a kind of human
way in which we understand what watson
did but this also reveals how
superficial
the processing techniques actually are
and on how unhuman-like they actually
are
so summarizing there you might say i
showed you that perspective from the
book super intelligence before you might
having seen behind the curtain
now balance that against the perspective
from this very funny book called how to
survive a robot uprising
this is by daniel wilson who is a
practitioner a roboticist
and this book is full of advice like if
you're being pursued by a robot
run up some stairs or be sure to wear
clothing that you know will
will confuse its vision system a much
more tempered perspective
so let's try to make that a little bit
more precise in terms of things that we
could take action on in a course like
natural language understanding that
falls under the heading of adversarial
testing
so just to get into our common ground
let me quickly review what
standard evaluations are like in
standard evaluations in nlu but actually
throughout the field of artificial
intelligence we work like this
you create a data set from some single
process you could scrape some data from
the web
or crowdsource a new data set or
something like that but the point is
that it's kind of homogeneous
in the next step you divide the data set
into disjoint
train and test sets and you set the test
set aside it's under lock and key
you develop your system on the train set
never once looking at the test set
and only after all development is
complete you finally evaluate your train
system
on that held out test set and the idea
is that that will provide you an
estimate of your system's capacity to
generalize to new cases
because after all you held that test set
under lock and key and only at the very
end
did you look at how your system behaved
with those entirely new examples
it sounds good it has a lot going for it
but i want to point out how
generous this is to the systems that
we're developing
because in step one we had a single
process
it's kind of too much to say that this
is actually going to be an estimate of
how the system will perform in the real
world because after all the real world
will throw in our system many more
diverse experiences than we saw in step
one and throughout
this process so adversarial testing kind
of embraces that right because in
adversarial testing
we make a slight tweak start by creating
a data set by whatever means you like it
could be just as before
you do develop and assess your system
using that data set again according to
whatever protocols you choose so this
part could be standard but here's the
new bit you develop a new test data set
of examples
that you suspect or know as a
practitioner
will be challenging given your system
and the original data set
and then of course only after all system
development is complete you evaluate
systems
on that new test set and you report that
number as an estimate of the system's
capacity to generalize
a lot of this is familiar except for the
introduction of this
new and potentially quite adversarial
data set
in the middle here this is kind of
simulating
what we saw when we looked behind the
curtain where entirely new examples that
the system developers didn't anticipate
were causing a lot of grief for our
otherwise very good systems
let's return to that nli problem let me
show you what this is like in practice
so remember this is that premise
hypothesis
prediction task with three labels in a
lovely paper by glockner at all
what they did is create a new
adversarial data set
that's kind of based on lexical
substitutions i actually hesitate even
to call this adversarial because i think
this is just kind of an interesting
challenge thing that they did so here's
how it worked
you have a fixed premise here it's a
little girl kneeling in the dirt crying
the original example had the hypothesis
a little girl is very sad
and that has the entailment relation
what they did is just use wordnet which
is a structured lexical resource
to substitute hear the word sad and have
it become the word unhappy
those are roughly synonymous so what we
would expect is that systems will just
continue to predict
the entailment relation for this new
adversarial example
everything else about the examples is
the same that's why i say this is
actually kind of a friendly adversary
here
what they found in practice is that
systems that are otherwise very good
are apt to predict something like
contradiction for the second case
it's probably because they think that
that negation in the word unhappy is a
good signal of contradiction
so they make a mistake and it's not a
very human mistake it's something very
systematic about
our understanding of a language like
english that we see that these two
are synonymous assuming we know what the
words mean this example down here is
similar where
you have the fixed premise and all
they've done is changed wine to
champagne
and that should cause a change from
entailment to neutral
but in fact since the system has a very
fuzzy understanding of how wine and
champagne relate to each other
it continues to predict entailment in
that case
this is a picture of the data set i
think it's really cool because it's got
a lot of examples
especially for contradiction and
entailment and it also has this
nice breakdown by individual categories
so you can get some real insights into
what it's doing
and as predicted this is quite
devastating for these systems so i have
a few models here that were very good
models at the time
they have very good snli test accuracy
that's one of those benchmark
tasks i mentioned before and their
accuracy on this new test set has
plummeted by you know as much as like 30
percentage points in absolute terms so
this is really devastating
now there is a ray of hope here
i'm not going to go into this slide in
detail of course because there's a lot
of information here i've put it here
just to say that our course has really
great coverage
of what are called transformer based
models you might have heard about them
like burt roberta electra excel net
by the end of the course you'll have a
very deep understanding of all the
technical details that you see here
for now though i would just want you to
think there has been a kind of really
interesting breakthrough in the last
two years related to how people use
these transformer based models
and the way i can give you a glimpse of
that let's just highlight roberta here
so what i've done on the next slide
is just use some of the course code from
our course
and some a pre-trained model that's easy
to access from
using facebook code so i read that model
in
and evaluate it on that full glockner at
all data set that i just showed you
and the result is amazing these are the
performance numbers here
the accuracy is at 0.97 and it's doing
extremely well for those two categories
where you have enough examples or enough
support
and remember just two years ago the best
system
on this adversarial test wasn't even
above 0.75 and now we're at 0.97
and doing well on both of these
categories that's starting to look like
yet again
some big leap forward and how well we
can do it's very exciting
now we can level up once more so just
quickly
so far we've been using adversaries just
for test sets
but we could actually have them be part
of the entire life cycle of a model
and that's what these authors have done
for the adversarial nli nri dataset this
is a direct response to the kind of
adversarial test failings we just saw
here's how this worked the annotator is
presented with a premise sentence
and a condition so a label they need to
produce entailment contradiction or
neutral
the annotator writes a hypothesis and
then a state-of-the-art model comes in
and makes a prediction about this new
premise hypothesis
pair if the model's prediction matches
the condition that is if the model was
correct
the annotator returns to step two and
tries again
and you could continue that loop until
the model is finally
fooled and you have a premise hypothesis
pair which you then validate with humans
so what's happening here by definition
is we're creating a data set that is
intuitive and natural for humans
but by definition very difficult for
state-of-the-art models because they are
now in the loop
where people are being adversarial with
them
it's a familiar picture this is the
current state of the art so we have a
few systems here that are outstanding on
snli
and multi-nli all these numbers in the
middle here
are different views of the adversarial
nli data set
and you can just see that they are
dramatically lower
than those standard evaluations on the
right so another unsolved problem we saw
a glimmer of progress
but i think now this is the new thing to
beat here and in fact we're going to
hear a bit more about these kind of
evaluations a bit later
so finally just by way of wrapping up i
don't want to take too much time but i
thought i could connect this really
nicely with our coursework so here's the
high level summary
we cover these topics on the left it's
by no means an exhaustive list of topics
for the field
but i think it's a good sample in the
sense that it gives you a picture of a
lot of different tasks
structures models techniques and metrics
so that if you're good at this sample of
topics you're really empowered to take
on anything
that's happening in the field of nlu
right now
part of the reason i feel confident
saying that is that the course is very
hands-on
so we have four assignments each paired
with a bake-off i'm going to tell you
about the bake-offs in a second
but each one of them is meant to be a
kind of simulation of a small
original final project and that
culminates or leads into the final
projects which come in a sequence of
things
that help you incrementally build up
from a literature review
through in a protocol and then finally
to a final paper
so that you've kind of with the help of
a teaching team mentor
slowly built to something that's an
original contribution in the field
for those assignments and bake-offs let
me just give you a glimpse of what the
rhythm of those is like
so each assignment culminates in a
bake-off which is an informal
competition in which you enter an
original model
this is like the kind of shared
evaluation tasks that you see a lot
throughout the field
the assignments ask you to build up some
baseline systems to inform your own
model design
and to build that original model and
then you enter that original model into
the system we have held out test sets
for you so that we really get a look at
how good your systems are
and the teams that win that get some
extra credit uh it's also important that
the
the teaching team assembles all of these
entries and reflects
insights from them back to the entire
group so that we can kind of
collectively learn
what worked and what didn't for these
problems the rationale of course behind
all this
is that each one of these should
exemplify best practices for doing nlu
and help make you an expert practitioner
i want to connect back with those
earlier themes and i think we have one
bake off that does that in a really
exciting way and this is a kind of
micro version of the nli task we do word
level entailment
where the training examples are pairs
like turtle animal
and a one means that they're in the
entailment relation turtle desk is in
the zero relation
so it's a small one-word version of that
full nli problem
the reason it connects with what i was
just covering is that we try to make
this a bit adversarial so
the train and test sets have disjoint
vocabularies
so for example if you do see turtle in
the train set
you won't find it anywhere in these
pairs that are in the tested examples
the idea is to really push systems to
make sure that they are learning
something that is
actually generalizable information about
the lexicon
as opposed to just benefiting from
idiosyncrasies kind of in the patterns
of the data
set that happen to exist so in that way
i think we can
push ourselves to develop systems that
really have robust
lexical knowledge embedded in them and
these tested evaluations give you a
glimpse of how much of that you've
actually achieved
there's an oh and just just to kind of
emphasize again how hands-on this all is
so this is a kind of full system for
that word uh level entailment problem
uh we don't need to dive into the
details of the code i'll just say that
you make essentially three
decisions here under glovevec this is
your choice of how to represent the
individual words
in this case i'm using glove pre-trained
representations glove is a model we
cover in some detail at the start of the
course
but of course you are free to make use
of any representation scheme you want
for these words you should also decide
how to represent the pairs here i've
chosen to just concatenate the two
representations but lots of things are
possible
and then i'd say finally the most
interesting and exciting part
falls under this network here so this is
a bit of pie torch code
it's using code that we release as part
of the course and that you'll make a lot
of use of
the reason that's important is that that
pre-built code
really frees you up to think creatively
about the problem at hand and you can
see that here this is a complete working
system
in cell 4. primarily what you do
for this assignment in bake off is work
on this build graph method where you're
essentially building the computation
graph for a deep neural network model
and then everything else about the
optimization process is handled by the
base classes which are already part of
the course repository
and that's important because it's hidden
away under base keyword arcs here
this model actually has lots of
different settings that you can explore
for different optimization choices and
other things so that you can really
experience in a hands-on way
how best to optimize these modern deep
learning models that you're building
i don't have time for it but i did just
want to mention this other bake off this
is a two there are four and all but this
is a really different one from the
previous ones if i had more time
with you i think the other theme that i
would emphasize would be
the importance of grounding natural
language outside of language and in
actual physical scenes and stuff like
that and the way we kind of explore that
in a tractable way
is by doing natural language generation
where we're trying to describe
color patches in context this is another
modeling direction
and it does bring in non-linguistic
information in the form of these color
patches
i think it's a really interesting
problem it kind of connects with
interesting topics in linguistics
and it's a chance for you to explore
another prominent class of models
which are these encoder decoder models
which process sequences
on the left this is not a linguistic
sequence these are color patches they
could be images
and on the right of course you're
producing a natural language description
but in the interest of time i think i'll
just go quickly to this wrap up
as i said before i really believe this
this is the most exciting
moment ever in history for doing nlu
it's not like you're joining the field
just at the moment when all the hard
tasks have been solved
i think rather we now have a good
foundation
for the really exciting breakthroughs
which are in the future and i think the
adversarial testing really makes that
clear
this course gives you hands-on
experience with a wide range of
challenging nlu problems
and when you come to do your original
research you'll have a mentor from the
teaching team
to guide you through not only the
project work but also all those
assignments and bake offs and so forth
and
you know the examples of success there
is that some of these things
have turned into really exciting and
mature papers some of them even
published and you're going to actually
hear about some of that really mature
and interesting work
in just a moment so the central goal of
course of all of this
is to make you the best that is most
insightful and responsible
nlu researcher and practitioner whatever
you decide to do next with all of this
new material
so i'll wrap up there thank you very
much
thank you chris this was extremely
interesting thank you
uh so if you have any questions for
chris feel free to post them in the q a
box we will be moving on right now to
allow
enough time for students to present
their projects
if you are interested in learning more
about a course
chris was mentioning or other courses a
cpd is offering
in artificial intelligence program like
machine learning or deep learning
you can check the links you will see on
your platform
but now we will move on so we will hear
from two project teams uh they took the
natural language understanding course
and developed great projects that they
will now briefly
present the first speaker will be gokan
chagrici
uh so gokan you can go ahead
yes hi everyone so yeah my name is
and my presentation is about the effecto
and stumbling on
a nli benchmark
and our focus keyword is basically
uh adversaries and uh
as you probably know the leaderboards
and uh these littles are
created for some challenging problems
but
most of them are using uh yeah each one
of these
are basically using a frozen corpus and
then there are practitioners and there
are researchers who are trying to beat
the best colors and this is how the life
cycle
goes but you might imagine that
it might not necessarily mean that you
are getting the best
uh kind of model that can generalize
into new
uh areas uh because of the
incapability of generalizing the idea
so that these models can take some
shortcuts
when you have a fixed kind of
training and test it so
here is a here is a paper one of the
latest papers
uh about like incorporating this
adversarial idea
and basically
uh as as professor pulse mentioned
uh it it is using different rounds
so there is round one uh which is
basically creating
this uh training set and this it and it
releases state of the art model
and based on the weaknesses of that
model and then
a new uh training and testing is being
created
taking those weaknesses into account
and uh this moves on so i used to
challenge the model
capability and uh increasing the
generalization capability before we move
on with the next slide
i would like to mention something so the
question is is it even easier for humans
right
for an nli task as you see
there are very simple kind of texts a
single sentence
text and very simple hypotheses based on
these
premises and these judgments are being
made by
humans you'll see that for the
for example the second example and the
last example even
humans cannot agree with the correct
label so
if this is the case for humans then how
how are we going to approach
this problem with uh with the machines
themselves
well as we said we will challenge
a model with a progressively harder
tasks
in my project i took the data set from
from the paper that i mentioned
and i applied several transformer-based
state-of-the-art models
so these models actually you'll see
three different models like
bird uh roberta and x on it
and there are two variants uh one is the
base one one is the large one
and for the output from y1 to y6 you see
the outputs per module
and for y7 there is a
strategy for assembling these models and
to see if and something is going to be a
cure for us
on the right uh
i wanted to give an uh a feeling about
the
uh the data set uh you see that
this data set contains very complex and
long kind of sentences
and there are a lot of named entities a
lot of relationships
references uh and
for the top three best performing models
for example for these two examples and
none of them could come up with the
right answers
so again we see that the task is very
hard
and for the question that i mentioned
let's see if ensembling
is the cure here right
well these are the results for the
models in isolation
we can look at just the f1 score because
it is one of the
score being used by the community a lot
for these
problems and even though
90 plus uh percent f1 scores have been
achieved
for snli and their variants
here we see that we couldn't even like
achieve a 50 percent
kind of iphone score and whenever we
applied and something
yes there is something from us we we
could barely see 51
percent for the f1 score but again it is
far from
uh like a reasonable kind of
success right so here
we see that just assembling
different models is not going to have
for
something that is so hard for the models
in isolation
and people are using assembling mostly
for
improving something that is already
improved by
by the by the individual models
so then the next reasonable question to
ask is okay
why are we still far away from a very
nice
kind of solution uh here is a list
so yeah model architecture can be an
issue
uh but personally i don't think it is it
is one of the most critical ones
the size of the training data is as
important as
[Music]
anything that anything in
other areas as well so if you have a
quality
if you have a high quality in terms of
the training data and test data then
you have a much better chance of
creating a satisfactory model but
here even creating a train data is very
expensive because
as we said even humans are having
trouble for
uh like agreeing with the output or
hypothesis and
uh and the premise itself so
uh it needs a lot of effort time and
money
uh but yes it is very important but the
last one is very interesting so
if you think of a child uh
that child's interaction with the
environment is
playing a very important role as well as
like reading some text
from some books and trying to analyze it
so that child is basically experimenting
with the external world all the time
and then creating new hypotheses and
testing it
creating another advertises i'm testing
it again so
machines are lacking this ability maybe
we are trying something that that cannot
be done
without these machines
living among us uh
and having said that i would like to
conclude with my experience
uh in terms of the project and the class
yes it is very demanding but
something should be very demanding so is
to give you a better insight into
into that topic uh and it should
challenge you so that you will
you'll feel the need to learn more and
that comes
actually uh that is mentioned in the
rewarding part
so you gain the discipline of analyzing
papers
uh searching and comparing the results
and then
trying to repeat those results or even
go
beyond those results and last but not
the least
the guiding part uh
it does not matter what kind of
questions you are having but there is a
very strong
kind of community from
stanford uh helping i didn't even see
any
any question that that that was not
answered by
uh by those expert people including uh
professor potts
and yeah i'm really happy to be here and
uh thanks for your time
and yeah see you soon
thank you gokan thank you for your time
and presenting your project
uh to everybody and now we can move on
to the other project
that was developed by mohan rangarajan
wupang
and ethan guin so mohan
will now let you know a little bit more
about it
thank you petra hi everyone this is
mohan uh it's a privilege
to be presenting here on on behalf of my
team ethan nooyan and wu farm
and it's we're certainly looking forward
to this
this quote by mahatma gandhi actually
captures the essence
of how we approach both the course and
the project
we had a learning mindset and we said we
are going to learn
at whatever whatever will be the cost
right when we actually approach the
project work we wanted to do something
in in question answering obviously and
with knowledge graphs using knowledge
graphs
right like many people and like
professor parts mentioned earlier
we were enamored with bert transformers
and the birth variants and the whole
notion of contextual embedding
right we were curious to see how
contextual embedding would improve
accuracy
and so our hypothesis was really about
using knowledge graph and seeing if
contextual embedding would improve the
accuracy
you may ask hey how did you come from
this broad topic to
to to a specific focused hypothetical
right
and here we have to really talk about
the structured approach that professor
potts mentioned you know doing the
literary review
and then the experimental protocol and
then going on to the project
this really helped us narrow down to a
specific
focused topic on the hypothesis
so on the left hand side what you see
here really is the broad
area that we were wanting to initially
look at right
and then uh you know one thing that we
talked about is as we did the literary
review
we realized that oh you know what we
have to kind of narrow
down our focus and then we sought
guidance from our course facilitator
and you know based on that direction and
also
looking at how much computer resources
we have and the time available
we narrow down to the natural language
back in portion of this topic
and even within that we chose the simple
questions data set
and the now for the knowledge graph we
chose an embedded approach
to represent the knowledge graph which
was based on freebase
i would be remiss if i don't point out
here that
we had complete freedom in choosing the
topic
choosing our hypothesis and so the
outcome
really was not a concern right because
the evaluation is going to be on the
methodology and the rigor
that uh that that we are going to have
right
and so that kind of freed us from the
pressure that comes with oh
our hypothesis should actually improve
the results to focusing more on the
methodology
and the concurrence and the results
there
here's our our experiment so we had
three fundamental tasks in the project
one was the entity learning the other
one was predicate and the third one was
entity detection
the entity learning and predicate
learning models were primarily used for
predicting the entity and the predicate
in the simple question and the entity
detection model
was useful for collecting a set of
tokens that would represent entity names
for the knowledge graph we use freebase
and we use the embedded representation
that that was needed for the entity and
the predicate
so the idea here really is we present
the entity
we present the entity detection the
tokens in the entity detection to the
knowledge graph
and we retrieve a set of candidate facts
and then
the tail entity associated with the
facts would yield our possible answer
right so the closest fact since we were
using embedding
the fact that was closest to the
embedding representation of the entity
and the predicate
would result in the answer for the
question
so that was kind of in essence what uh
what our model was and what our
experiment was about
here is a little bit of detail on the
model itself the entity and predicate
learning models were very similar
right but the entity detection model was
slightly different in the sense that you
know each token had to be assessed as to
whether it would be a potential
entity name or not
looking at the results and analysis uh
you know
we should say that it we were quite
pleased
that there was marginal improvement in
the
in the model that in the model that we
were using as compared to
the baseline model but i used the word
marginal because
as you can see it was an improvement
right
since we were using knowledge graphs we
were also wanting to compare the results
if we didn't use an embedded
representation of the knowledge graph
and we were kind of uh it was
interesting to note
that from the results then for the
individual tasks that is entity learning
and predicate learning and entity
detection
right the scores for
using the knowledge graph directly
without using embedding was better
right and but the interesting part is
when we were actually doing the
evaluation on the test set
we noticed that the embedding based
approach
had better results compared to the
approach without
embedding and of course you know the
marginal improvement
in accuracy was higher compared to
the baseline models that we were using
right so the interesting part really
here is
you know while we were kind of pleased
with the marginal improvement
we also noticed that the execution time
associated with our models
was uh was you know much slower
you know our fastest variant was twice
as slow as the original model that was
in the baseline
right and so the interesting part here
is you know
we were then puzzled as to okay you know
did contextual embedding really help
in this problem or no right and
the other part here is you know
we concluded then that you know this the
training duration is low
the improvements and my accuracy were
marginal
so we felt it was less compelling to use
a fine-tuned birth model
for simple question answering
applications in the real world
a big generalization to make but that
was our conclusion based on
the simple questions data set and the
other part to also note
here is we chose the measure accuracy
because it was a simple question
a question answering solution right so
either the answer is correct
or incorrect so what did we learn from
this exercise right
so i think it's important to understand
the data set that you're using for your
testing
right when we actually you know started
the project with with our hypothesis
we felt that we are going to actually
you know have at least 90 percent
accuracy considering all the wonderful
things
bert and the bert variants are have done
actually right and then we realized
we're kind of a bit deflated with
uh our question you know we're not
performing as well
and we did a little bit more research
only to realize that you know there is a
cap of 83.4
accuracy on the model i mean on the um
you know as far as
using simple questions dataset is
concerned right and this is because
there's a high prevalence of
unanswerable questions and some
questions don't have any
ground truths in the knowledge graph
right the other
part as well is you know apart from
other things
we have now a deep appreciation for the
level of effort required
to hypothesize research experiment and
author a paper
that conforms to acl standards
i'd like to quote isaac newton here by
saying if i have seen further it is by
standing on the shoulder of giants
we really have a lot of people that we
should thank for xiaohuang and the team
whose works served as a launching pad
for our our work here
salman muhammad and the team whose work
we use as a baseline for comparing our
our model the hugging phase company
whose transformer based models allowed
us to compare different variants
professor parts thank you so much you
know we learned a ton of new things in
this
in this course your active
active participation in the slack
channel and your enthusiasm
was a welcome and pleasant surprise our
course facilitator pradeep cheema and
other course facilitators
that helped us they're always there to
help and encourage us with our work and
lastly steve it will be here ms if you
don't mention you for helping us
throughout the course
thank you so much thank you mohan
thank you for presenting the project i
think it's very exciting thank you for
joining us also ethan and wu who are
here with us
but not not visible at this moment but
they are here
uh i think we can move on to do q and a
session
uh we got some interesting questions
from the audience so thank you everybody
also for your questions
uh i will now ask chris um
the first question so are the
adversarial examples generated by
humans exclusively or by computational
models
such as generative adversarial network
yeah that's a great question so you
really see a full spectrum of approaches
in some cases humans have just written
new adversarial cases as you saw with
goken's project with the adversarial nli
dataset
sometimes we can do sort of
quasi-automatic stuff like with wordnet
uh where we just do some lexical
substitutions and kind of we can assume
that the meaning that we want is
preserved or changed in a systematic way
but you can also have models in the loop
acting as adversaries
there have been some applications of
generative adversarial networks in nlu
to kind of
make sure these models are robust the
picture seems
more mixed than you get from vision
where i know gans have really been a
powerful force for good and
making models more robust so i think
there's some space for innovation there
but the general picture would be i think
we can think really flexibly and
creatively
about how to create those adversarial
tests and that just creating one could
have its own
modeling interest in addition to that
that serving as a kind of weight new way
to evaluate models
so lots of space for innovation there
okay great um i hope it answered the
question
um the next question uh is
about electra based transformer uh so is
electra-based transformer more robust
to adversarial examples compared to mlm
based transformers such as
bird oh interesting open question
so elektra's primary motivation i think
is to make
more efficient use of its data than bert
does we have a nice little lecture on
on electra and how it works and kind of
why it's successful
um but the in the paper if i remember
correctly there isn't an evaluation that
you would call adversarial
they mostly just post better numbers on
the standard data sets and explore a
really wide range of variations on the
electra model both how it deals with
data
and how it's structured but again i love
that question it's just so interesting
to ask for a model that seems to be a
step forward
here not only in terms of accuracy but
also in terms of efficient use of data
and compute resources
what is it doing on these very human but
ultimately very challenging
adversarial data sets great question to
address
yeah and it's especially fruitful if you
can address that question
and then be maybe think about how the
answer could inform
an improvement to a model like electra
because then you have that full cycle of
the adversary
helping us do innovative things with the
models we're building
okay great um the next question
it seems that there is no adversarial
training in this product
but only adversarial testing would
adverse your training fit into this
particular
for nlu or how would it work for sure
yeah so actually uh adversarial nli the
data set that cocaine talked about
that is large enough that you can use it
for training in addition
to assessment and there are a few other
data sets that are like that
um very few of them were created
with the kind of full human in the loop
stuff that you saw with adversarial nli
some of them have more automatic model
based means of creating the
data sets that are large enough for
training but that's on the horizon and
in fact one of the visionary statements
that the adversarial nli paper makes
is that we should move into a mode of
kind of
continually retraining and evaluating
our models
on data sets that were created
adversarially and that that kind of
ongoing process which is a more
fundamental change to how we do system
development
is a kind of way to lead to even more
robust systems
so so my my quick answer would be we
should be looking for ways
to scale the adversarial testing
paradigm so that we can have
training sets as well
um so what is the current state of
research and applications of deep rl
to nlu a part of transformers uh if
there is
research in it how promising is it for
you or
how promising do you find it
interesting question so
the overall i would say the vision of
reinforcement learning
really resonates with me you know if you
think about your life
as an agent in the world trying to learn
things and experience the environment
you don't get direct reward signals
right you only get very indirect
feedback and you have credit assignment
problems you don't know how to update
your own parameters and so forth so you
have to make a lot of guesses
and it's a kind of chaotic process but
nonetheless that's the world we live in
and we all learn effectively so
something like that set of techniques
has to be brought more fully into the
field i think we're seeing really
exciting stuff
in the area of combining deep rl with
grounded language understanding and
certainly with dialogue
and i'm sure there are other areas so
it's a great space to explore the models
tend to be
hard to optimize and hard to kind of
understand
but that's part of the journey toward
making them really effective for the
problems we look at
i'll give a quick plug i did some stuff
that i thought was really exciting that
tried to use
reinforcement learning together with
transformer-like models
to induce more modularity so that the
systems that we developed instead of
having very diffuse
sort of solutions would do things that
looked more like
encompassing lexical capabilities and
specific functionality
and those are called recursive routing
networks again hard to tune
but obviously an inspiring idea and
you know we should just keep keep
pushing those techniques
um maybe one very general question where
do you see future of nlu
what are the how it will look like in
the next few years
oh five years starting to seem like a
long time i mean after all my short
lecture
showed you that in just a two year span
we had what looked like a real phase
change on some hard problems so five
years
feels like an eternity so just some
predictions i could make
you know the idea behind contextual word
representations which is primarily how
transformer based architectures are used
that's powerful and that's going to last
it really has changed things
and i think the vision there is that
like more chances to have
contextual understanding more chances to
be embedded in a context that's going to
be important
grounded language problems are going to
be more prominent and i think that's
going to lead to breakthroughs because
after all
human learners don't learn just from
text that's kind of an absurd idea
human learners learn from the social
environment
lots of inputs that they get in addition
to language input so to the extent that
our systems can be multimodal like
that they're probably going to get
better
i hope as a personal thing that we as a
field do more
to break free of the confines of always
looking at english i saw briefly in the
q a there was a question about
whether or not the field just looks at
english
the big data sets tend to be in english
but i think that
that's changing a little bit for example
in the nli
problem we now have some good
multilingual data sets and that's
important because english is not
representative of the world's languages
and
if we look more farther afield we might
lead
that might lead us to new kinds of
models that would count as again
fundamental breakthroughs
so that's going to be important and then
we should all be thinking much more
now that our systems are more useful and
more often deployed
we should be thinking more holistically
like not just that my system did well in
some narrow evaluation but
what is it actually doing out there in
the world when it interacts with real
examples
and real users and where the fundamental
thing should be
we should be assessing making sure that
those systems are having a positive
impact
as opposed to causing some social
process to go awry or something like
that
so that's the kind of new responsibility
we have that's coming from
the recent successes so a welcome
challenge but an important one
okay great thank you um yeah actually at
the time
almost so i would like to spend the last
minute thanking you for your time to
take part in this webinar
also both or all of them gokan also
ethan also mohan osobu who joined us
today
i think it was really interesting
exciting that they joined us and they
talked about the project
so they brought in an actual life uh the
course materials
so thank you all for joining us i hope
you
participants enjoyed it and if you are
interested more
in learning more about the courses in ai
professional
uh certificate uh feel free to check the
links
uh we are offering uh um uh in the
interface
or please feel free to contact us also
directly
so thank you everybody and stay safe and
healthy
thanks petra yeah and thanks to the
project teams those presentations were
really great i found that really
inspiring
you